I have a new tour date to announce
spring daily Utah on July 6th at the OC
Tanner Amphitheater the pre-sale begins
Wednesday March 8th at 10 A.M local time
with code rat king and the General on
sale begins Friday March 10th at 10 A.M
local time we've added a fourth Show in
Las Vegas Nevada on July 1st at The
Encore Theater
I will also be in Hollywood Florida on
April 7th at Hard Rock Live that's the
day before the Miami UFC fights we will
be in Uncasville Connecticut July 21st
Bethlehem PA July 22nd and Atlantic City
New Jersey on July 23rd all tickets are
available at theovan.com t-o-u-r
today's guest is an award-winning singer
and songwriter he's written for some of
the greats like Morgan Wallen and Blake
Shelton
he has a new solo album the Mockingbird
and the crow which he's out touring with
right now uh I've gotten to know him
over the past few years and there is no
one
just more down to earth and enjoyable to
be around than this man today's guest is
Hardy
[Music]
[Applause]
I live like I could walk here I would be
tired but I could walk here could you
really yeah I mean I would be tired it
would take me
all right so it would take you so it
would take you how long to walk here I
mean maybe 30 minutes but it was like
two miles it's like a mile and a half
but that's not walking somewhere that's
your at that point you're you're
hitchhiking yeah kind of I could bum a
rod here yeah yeah there you go for sure
yeah I could bum a ride here that's I
feel like that feels like a better
statement yeah that's I don't know why
people don't use that like because
because technically you know how they're
like you could walk there and like
technically you could pretty much walk
any like you could walk anywhere yeah
and so you had to swim or whatever but
yeah you could walk almost like it's
crazy it's crazy to think of the old
days when people were like
I'll head over and they get out there
like four hours oh yeah anything
Anything could happen between them like
you wouldn't know yeah like you'd have
to be like you'd have to call somebody
on a pay phone and be like I'll see you
on Saturday
and before payphones it was like by
letter it was like I'll be there next
month and then they never showed up and
they just like got killed by a bear or
something
or people like like a parent showed up
and they're like where's our daughter
and the guy's like us you know she
[__] died she went to get some water
and I haven't seen her he's lying I took
her he took her life yeah exactly that's
like some Game of Thrones [__] dude oh
it's heartbreaking man yeah we live in a
we live in a more convenient time than
than ever yeah it's pretty wild it's so
yeah things are almost too convenient
now it is dude we I've I've somebody
needs to do a study on this but I get I
think that like do you remember like in
the 90s 80s whenever but that when you
heard a song on the radio that you loved
and you the next time you got to hear
that song was on the radio yeah so and
that was so euphoric to hear that song
again because you didn't have access to
it where now it's like if you like one
song you can go listen to every single
thing that artist or whatever has ever
done yeah and back then you had the the
luxury of having that euphoric moment of
like oh having that to yourself you know
and then having to like record it on the
on the [__] on the cassette yeah yeah
yeah well it almost felt magical too
like if it came on at a certain moment
it was like that world that was like the
gods telling you this is it you know
yeah like oh I was driving by and this
played and there he was yeah and you had
no control over it it just had to happen
to you yeah now you can sit outside of
somebody's house for like seven hours
and play the same song over and over
again you know until the cops show up
and take you somewhere yeah exactly but
it's like you couldn't have before you
couldn't yeah you couldn't build up that
dirty momentum like you can now uh
dang dude that is so crazy things see
but then think of how much power the DJ
had back then yeah because he's like you
know what right now I feel things out
there kind of slipping slipping out of
our grasp when we put you guys on
something and he put out a love tune
yeah yeah or like we are the world you
know what I mean like oh he controlled
The Narrative of people's lives back in
the day
it's pretty crazy DJ was powerful wasn't
he
it was always like the DJ had a dance it
was like that but for the whole city or
a nation it was like when that song came
on it was like this is what everybody's
gonna feel if somebody right now is like
if two spouses are fighting or whatever
the casserole went good I'm about to hit
him with this love ballad and
everything's gonna change yeah and
that's the only way that they could hear
it they couldn't do it themselves let's
see how to a violin or something yeah or
a capability yeah you know yeah yeah
yeah you had to have a real capability
yeah something like that
um
Hardy good to see you man happy to be
here man I know I'm stoked yeah thank
you so much for your time man you guys
are I know you were uh or post your
flight or let or leaving tomorrow now I
really appreciate you making the time
dude I am a lot I'm glad to make it man
um I'm so happy for your career dude
thank you it's been awesome past couple
years has been incredible bro I didn't
know you are such a it's almost like
going to a
Fitness him it is like going to a dang
show yes when you go see Hardy if you
have not if you haven't gone to see
Hardy then you you need to go see him
um you're going to be touring with
Morgan and doing what do you what do you
have right now I'm on I have my first
like real Live Nation like headliner
tour Mockingbird and the crow tour and
we're like
a quarter of the way through it now it's
only like 20 shows so uh like five
weekends but uh yeah this summer I'm
doing the uh uh I guess it's called one
night at a time tour with Morgan I
should know I should be more confident
with that but I think that's what it's
called when Morgan uh Ernest
uh and Bailey Zimmerman and then Parker
McCollum is going to when I there's some
shows that I can't do because I had
other shows booked so he's he's doing
filling my spot when when I'm gone or
whatever nice and that's dude
like two nights at the biggest venues in
the world is like the craziest thing to
me uh it just like what do you mean when
you say when you're saying that you're
like like well just Morgan like I've
known him for so long now and like he
you know he's always just been Morgan
and and it's just it's so hard to
process that one of my friends is
literally quite literally the one of the
biggest artists on the planet like yeah
college football stadiums are the
biggest
[Music]
yeah dude yeah maybe even White Michael
Jack the Yeah well yeah yeah he's like I
don't know he's the Michael hat he's a
country yeah yeah yeah exactly dude but
no he's like Elvis Presley
kinda dude it's crazy yeah and like I
just I don't know I came up with him and
like
I I I like toured with him like he
brought me on my first tour as an opener
and we were doing like rooms of like 800
maybe to 2000 you know and just to know
that he's doing which is still like 80
000 people and [__] is [__]
unbelievable so proud of him man yeah oh
it's I mean it's I mean I've only known
you guys for maybe a couple years and
I went I got to go to some of his shows
last tour yeah but and it was amazing I
mean when Morgan goes on you know you've
heard I never realized that I could sing
for two hours straight like everybody
you know every single word everybody in
the whole place is singing it too which
is awesome yeah it's awesome but
watching you man it is like a fit it's
like
I'm like dang if that guy's wearing his
I just said that on an interview like an
hour ago that dude is he gonna step out
he's gonna beat his year somehow I get
fat when I go on tour dude I have no
idea how dude bro cause it yeah it's
just incredible man it's such a show bro
it's so powerful yeah I'm just it's I
don't know I just have the I feel like
I grew up like watching Rock shows and
then like I
FGL had me out a lot like early and I
got to watch their show and how active
they were and like I don't know I just
feel like I learned from that and that's
just kind of the only way I know how to
you know translate all that into mine or
whatever
yeah it feel and it just feels like it
fits you it feels like just like oh
you're just getting who Hardy is that's
what I'm feeling like oh wow yeah this
is who this guy is this is real exciting
yeah man it matches the music too
especially with like we're doing the
rock stuff now and and so it's the music
itself is really high energy so I feel
like I'm just having to keep up with my
the mute the songs you know oh damn
portray all that at the same time I
guess are there ones where you got to
take a couple breaths before you start
the bro yeah there's dude I there are
some songs that I am like suffocating
dude and I literally I'll just like hold
the mic out and be like you guys come on
but really I'm like just [__] dying
dude just trying to catch my breath and
have your fans are probably smokers dude
like no no you yeah you do it no you no
you and I'm like no [__] seriously
dude uh yeah there's times for sure man
like the first right now our set the
first six songs is like a ball buster
dude and it's awesome but there's like
no break and they're the first
five songs especially are like all the
the biggest like the heaviest like rock
songs and the biggest singing and
screaming songs so there's like no break
it's crazy that's fine exhausted but
it's fun yeah the new album's so
Mockingbird of the crow it's like um it
reminds me some of Kid Rock in a way
that's a yeah it reminds me of Kid Rock
and and then obviously country music
yeah you know so it's that's uh and
people see you look like Kid Rock too
dude do you remember
we were somewhere when you met Kid Rock
weren't we in the same place we were
dude it was uh Miranda Lambert opened
her bar yes the uh um oh man Casa Casa
Rosa or something like that yeah like a
Spanish bar yeah yeah yeah in downtown
and uh yeah she had a big big
star-studded thing there we go yeah and
people and people had always told you
you guys look like each other well damn
yeah dude I get it I'm seeing more memes
and stuff now yeah and I like that night
when we met like he already knew about
it apparently so like he made a joke he
like was like my long lost brother which
kind of that because because I I was a
huge fan of Kid Rock back in the day
like massive and still am and I know him
now which is crazy but I love him and
and um
yeah so heathel's in on the joke and
like the first thing he did is like took
my hat off and put his hat I was like
let's take a picture you know Twins or
whatever it was cool yeah but yeah that
was that night I was I forgot about that
that was really cool yeah I think I
honestly I think I might have taken one
of those pictures I don't have to look
through my pictures and see
um yeah so where did some of that that
come from for you so because some guys
don't have that both sides of that thing
they're really they're in one world kind
of but you don't you really want that's
you have a foot in both yeah in both
boots man I tell everybody like I grew
up in a small town and you know country
you know I grew up 8 000 people and uh
probably real similar to Covington right
yeah yeah similar just just small small
ass town and so
like growing up that's everything
lifestyle wise I absorbed so that's like
that's where all the country comes from
and the lyrics and all that stuff that's
how I grew up but like I did not listen
to country music at all who listened to
music in your house everybody my music
other than like God you know like music
was number two behind you know religion
in my in my house like like uh
there was always music playing my sister
was a really good singer
uh my dad didn't play or sing but he was
like obsessed with rock and roll and my
mom played piano so I mean music was you
know it was huge in my house so I had no
choice but to be obsessed with it
growing up do you remember like the
first song you ever heard kind of yeah
really I I have a vivid memory dude it
was uh Alive by Pearl Jam oh dude I know
where we were in Philadelphia in
Philadelphia Mississippi yeah we were in
my dad's truck and he had a cassette and
he said listen to this this is a band
called Pearl Jam and he put the cassette
in and that riff from a live started
playing it was like something out of a
movie dude my brain chemistry just
changed and I was like what the [__] is
this and I was like four but I remember
it's one of my first dude amazing it
changed my life forever
did you and was it just you and your dad
in that in that moment yeah yeah
yeah and he he saw it like then like he
he was like okay this you know thank God
like my son loves rock and roll or
whatever and so
from then until I could like drive
basically every time we got in the truck
it was something new Aerosmith was easy
top you know and but it was never
country he he liked a little bit of like
Merle Haggard and like I guess if you
call John Prine country like but he knew
he never played it was always rock and
roll so I owe all of my and then I found
you know then I got into like by the my
like Prime setting like teen you know
angst or music influence years was like
Linkin Park and like puddle of Mud and
all that new metal Limp Biscuit and all
that [__] so I've kind of discovered
that on my own but I owe all of my
childhood like music
taste or whatever to my dad it was all
classic rock yeah there's something
interesting um because Lainey Wilson was
just on here yeah listen to it yeah
she's great yeah awesome yeah dude she
like
I mean yeah she's magical and you guys
have that great song together man
um wait in the truck yeah and uh so but
I was thinking like and I was talking on
there about the first time that I heard
a song I was with my babysitter and I
wonder sometimes if there's like
something about just you and your dad
together like sometimes it takes like a
certain like uh
I don't know what I'm thinking exactly
like because I remember it was that I
was alone with I'd never been in a car
with somebody that wasn't like probably
all my brothers and sisters at the same
time or all of us I was like my
babysitter was taking me somewhere so it
was me and her right it was just like
this moment and then she put in a
cassette and so my senses were already
real alert yeah yeah yeah that's
interesting I never really thought about
it like that but I'm sure you and your
dad are probably going different places
together but that's cool that he put
that in dude imagine if there's like a
dad and he puts like a good song on for
the kid and the kid doesn't give a [__]
dude
they're coming from a music family like
it would have broken my dad's heart if I
would have just looked and said like I
don't I don't like this can you just
turn it can we sit in silence a
four-year-old just asking if he could
turn it off this hurts my ears or
something dude bro that would be so
crazy he would have he would have died
he would have hated that or the dad even
puts on something that's kind of like
just not even that great and the kids
like this is trash yeah because Dad like
loves his favorite song it's just the
kids like this [__] sucks
that would have been horrible dude I
hope that does not happen to me dude
that would break my heart if I have a
kid one day I know that would have to be
such a heartbreaker you know I think
about that a lot like imagine if your
kid isn't smart and you have to like
wish him good luck on a test or
something when he leaves for school
and you know like the luck isn't
Nothing's Gonna help I I feel like
parents probably go through that though
you know what I mean like your kid sucks
that [__] volleyball out of soccer I
don't know but you go out you just have
like your kid likes it for whatever
reason and you just have to go watch him
like fail until they lose interest in it
oh that's crazy though if you have a kid
who like
he loves like just not even being good
at it kind of but he still wants to go
because usually kids want to stop going
if they're not good yeah but I guess
when you're like a young kid I don't
know that's I I don't know what would go
on in a kid's mind but like t-ball you
know like if they're horrible
like does the kid is the kid old enough
to be like I'm not very good I don't
feel like a kid would say I'm not very
good at this I don't want to do it
anymore maybe maybe like seven or eight
but when they're real little maybe not
and then you have to have that talk like
you know like if especially parents that
grew up like you know middle class or
whatever you want to call it and like
they're spending money you know on this
thing and they're you know the kid's
terrible like does the parents sit them
down and say like look maybe you should
find something that's you're gonna
actually be better at so we don't we're
not spending our money on this wasteful
[__] I don't know yeah that's wild I
think that's kind of
yeah I'm trying to think of what I
played I think I play Oh our team was uh
did you play baseball oh dude I was bad
I was under I couldn't even believe I
was so bad at baseball dude yeah in the
field we played on was like slanted
right we had a bed so slanted down so
what so would a home run be easier to
hit though like
because you know in golf like if it's
downhill it's technically shorter oh no
that would have been great ours was just
slanted over to the side to right field
so every like kind of if you hit it to
third it ended up like out in center
field
so it was what was the name of your part
um
oh we played out at uh Cordell furniture
an American Legion okay American Legion
yeah that's everybody use a plated
American League yeah yeah yeah ours was
Northside Park but then I'm pretty sure
the American Legion was like right
behind the Park yeah it's like that
comes as a package deal it's like the
National Guard the fire station and the
Americans yeah right yeah especially
like in a smaller community that stuff
is awesome yeah
um so what was Philadelphia like you're
from Philadelphia Mississippi what was
it kind of like man I loved it dude it
sounds like a perfect size eight
thousands it's the most cliche in a way
the most cliche in the best way like
small town dude like when you hear like
a cliche ass country song about the
courthouse square and the whole deal
yeah it's it is the definition of a
small town but dude it you know I hear a
lot of people I meet a lot of people
that are like talk about where they're
from and they're like I'm glad I got out
of that [__] and like I had never
felt that way I absolutely loved my
hometown yeah it was really cool and
there was obviously you know like drama
and everything it was all there was just
as much that is the good but I was just
very
thankful for my time there and I still
love to go we had it dude the coolest
thing about my hometown is we have a
county fair and this is worth a Google
called the Nashoba n-e-s-h-o-b-a Nashoba
County Fair okay Neshoba County Fair so
that's see all's County was in Neshoba
County Mississippi I think it means like
uh it's
Choctaw yeah and it's I think it means
like wolf or something like that I'm not
sure I could be wrong or I could be
completely wrong about that but dude so
this fare is everything else about it is
just like a county fair you have horse
races all the whole thing but you but
you have like 800 of these cabins and
they're all family owned and you you
move out there
uh for an entire week and it's the heat
of the summer it's hot as [__] and you
being from Louisiana in the like the end
of July dude it's brutal but and you
live out there and if they air
conditioning like you know AC units and
all that kind of stuff or window units
and stuff but dude it's it's the most
fun it's the most unique thing ever
because the town literally shuts down
and everybody in the little Quadra
County area just goes to the fair and
you you people take off work like and
you stay out there and just kind of
party and hang out for a week and it's
amazing and the the houses and stuff
they're around a lake or they're around
oh it's around the around the
fairgrounds picture it like a giant like
Cookie Cutter neighborhood somewhere
okay there's like 10 rows here and then
you kind of go over and there's a little
section here with a long row and then
back over here but the the the like
Cornerstone of it is around there's
cabins that wrap around the racetrack
and that's like the cool picture-esque
but there there's 800 of them and they
dude it's it's like 200 years old or
something crazy like that they're
family-owned dude they get broken up in
divorces and wills you there if somebody
sells one you can sell them for like
half a million dollars it's a really
cool
little piece of like Americana South
that's like kind of still undiscovered I
can't believe like Barstool Sports or
somebody hasn't gone out and like kind
of blown it up yet but it's a really
cool Little Gym of the South wow you've
never can you zoom in on one of those
please uh Ben I've never even seen I've
never even heard of this
the Neshoba County Fair yeah man have
you played it yet I did I got to play it
uh I was supposed to play it 2020 I got
first year got canceled since the Civil
War not since the Civil War World War II
um since the depression I believe and
um but so it got canceled so I played it
in 2021 and it was like it's like three
top three like bucket list places that
you know and I got to play it and it was
incredible wow it's really really cool
and do people come in from around to see
it or is more just the locals kind of go
well the locals it's the locals like
have the cabins right okay and then like
you'll have a you'll have a crew like
from Jackson That's had a cabin for
forever or maybe from Louisiana or like
a town we know family from Texas that
somehow has a cabin that come every year
but like a lot of people from around the
state will come for like a night like
the first weekend and the last weekend
it starts on a Friday ends on Friday you
know and like so people from all over
will take off work and like crash with a
friend or go and come or whatever but uh
for the most part the people that live
around there are the ones that have the
cabins wow you guys can't see it I mean
if you see it on YouTube maybe you can
see some of these pictures but it's
beautiful I mean yeah they have all
these homes are beautifully colored and
yeah it's like a Bourbon Street kind of
vibe honestly and then it mixed with
like college football every a lot of
cabins are like Ole Miss or Mississippi
State Southern Miss like decorated yeah
kind of thing ours is a big Mississippi
State cabin gang baby yeah wow that's
nice man really cool this episode is
brought to you by betterhelp and we are
grateful for them
if you if you struggled if you do
struggle if you don't feel like you're
yourself if you feel like you're just
not fitting into the world or into your
life the way that you want to you may
need someone to talk to
and that's okay
sometimes we need someone else to help
us get to know ourselves and better help
can do that
therapy is all about deepening your
self-awareness and understanding because
sometimes we don't know what we want or
why we react the way we do until we talk
through things better help connect you
with a licensed therapist who can take
you on that journey of self-discovery
from wherever you are
if you're thinking of starting therapy
give better help a try it's entirely
online designed to be convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
get matched with a licensed therapist
and and I love this you can switch
therapists anytime for no additional
charge and I encourage you to do that if
you're seeing a therapist you don't know
if it's the right fit you don't feel
like you're getting somewhere switch
until you find the right one
discover your potential with better help
visit
betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o today to get 10 off your first
month hey fellas
it's all about confidence you know it
confidence knowing you'll be ready to go
when your partner is ready to go
and confidence you'll be able to get a
few extra rounds when you need them
confidence is what you get with
chewables
from Bluetooth
is a unique online service that delivers
the same active ingredients as Viagra
and Cialis but in chewable
form at a fraction of the cost that's
right
you want to get all you want to get
ready boy you want to be readied up you
want to have that rooster ready for Mama
and now they have Varden Apple mint
flavor two apples with the ingredient
the active ingredient in Levitra and
staxon so you can stay hard and fresh
you want that fresh wean baby get it
Bluetooth licensed medical providers
work with you to find the right
ingredient and strength for your
prescription I like blue chew I snack on
them
don't like swallowing pills no problem
here
Bluetooth sildenafil and toddle laughing
tablets are chewable that's right
and guys here's a special deal for you
try Bluetooth free when you use our
promo code Theo at checkout just pay
five dollars shipping that's
bluechew.com promo code Theo to receive
your first month free and would your
folks do in town like for a living my
dad was a chicken farmer
um and my mom was a food service manager
for Philadelphia High School I went to
Nashoba Central County school but my mom
was the food service manager so she like
was the lunch lady's boss and like oh
damn deals and you know like she had a
big spatula yeah yeah but my dad was a
chicken farmer was he really yeah wow so
did y'all have extra chickens at the
house as pets and stuff no way he didn't
bring anything this was like this was
like
Tyson chicken dude like oh he's working
out there one of the 100 yard long
houses with 27 500 chickens in a house
and they're violent aren't they those
animals yeah like game roosters are
these chickens were like
I don't know politically correct they
were not Specialists it's fine I was in
special ed yeah they were they were they
were that kind of deal like they're yeah
but they challenged chickens yeah look
let's be honest what they're giving
people look you ain't get if you getting
a McNugget you ain't getting the best
chicken no you're not and these things
man you ain't getting a Harvard bird you
ain't getting a [__] yeah exactly
you're not getting the ones that are
like on pictures on websites yeah yeah
these were like different they would
start like this big and in seven weeks
they'd be a seven pound chicken they
were pumping them things full of I don't
even know what I did and were they sit
on like a little gym I mean what do they
do and then they don't move huh no
they're just packed in a house that the
floor is literally chicken [__] oh man
and uh and uh it's just it's crazy it's
the way it is man and and uh there's a
feed line and there's tons of like it's
just a long feed line and it has a
little Reservoir and they eat and
there's water and uh my dad had this
thing called a cake machine scene and it
literally it was designed for chicken
houses that you would go in after they
catch all the chickens because the [__]
would be so compacted after they you
know the people and all the chickens
have been in there and it would break up
the chicken [__] and lay it back out
like dry and like soft for those
chickens cake machine wow
and is that a real machine that they
have yeah I mean it was it breaks up
chicken [__] and then what lays it back
out like almost killing the soil yeah
it's literally it's kind of like that
but it pro it like goes into this it's
like a big machine and you would scoop
it up and it would go through the
machine somehow and I I think it would
like dry it and just it turns it into
powder again and lays it back down every
time they would catch you'd have to go
back to there it's like mowing grass but
it's like scooping up chicken [__] yeah
wow we had a turkey Farmer on really
yeah it was real interesting just
learning about how quick they get them
ready for Thanksgiving really you know
and how they like change the lights in
there and stuff to make them think that
it's day and night and stuff like that
yeah I think maybe my dad did some of
that too it's kind of like that saw like
saw the movie you know big saw Vibes
dude for sure like if I
if I if reincarnation is a thing that's
one of the last things if not the last
thing I'd want to come back it would be
one of those chickens dude it's a really
shitty life man
yeah we're doing better than them yeah
um what uh I'm trying to think there's a
bunch of stuff that I wanna that I want
to talk to you about what was it what
was I looking at earlier that I was
thinking about
um whenever you whenever you start
getting into Tunes like what is the
first instruments that you get like who
gets you keyed into music like obviously
your stuff your dad was listening to you
liked it yeah your mom's playing music
around the house yes right so you're
hearing a lot of good Tunes when do you
start to really get like an ear like oh
this is something that I'm kind of good
at I got I got a guitar when I was
little
um I got like my parents got me like a
little Fender Squier like 100 guitar and
a little guitar amp when I was like
probably fifth or sixth grade and I
picked it up I learned like the bar
chord like the easiest [__] like Smoke
on the Water and crap like you know what
I mean like oh yeah Alabama and just all
the [__] that everybody learns The
Stairway to Heaven no not even bro I
couldn't that was that was like expert
level compared to the [__] I was
learning yeah damn but um
yeah and I picked that up and then like
I got I I went into my teen years and I
kind of put it back down and then I
picked it up again when I was like 16 or
17 and that's when I like started to
really I like figured out like right
songwriting and like all that kind of
stuff and like actually learning a
little bit more about the guitar and
getting a little bit better and stuff
was like like later in high school
and do you feel more like a performer
did you feel like a writer like when you
when you think about what you felt like
that Drew you to something you know like
like sometimes with comedy like I don't
know if I think of myself as a writer I
think of myself as a performer right
it's like me right and yeah like a
performer sure did you have one or did
you have a man it was writing for me
dude it was riding for me until five
years ago like I moved to town to be a
songwriter and um my goal was to write
hits for people
and then
um so that I always had that I mean like
in like in my favorite class in school I
liked like biology because I loved
animals and like being outside and all
that kind of stuff but I I was not a
very good student but I excelled
randomly in writing I was I always had a
really good knack for whether it was
like essay you know like short story
whatever you had to write in school
and uh I just had a knack for it and I
was obsessed with it like knowing that I
had the ability to create a story or
make something up or say something in
writing was always like really important
to me for whatever reason and now I know
why like that was just a like that was
the gift that God gave me I guess was my
interest in writing or whatever and um
but so I I that's it was always riding
and then
um the record like the the artist thing
you know people say doing the artist
thing that came around the time like
Morgan's up down was a hit like because
that was my first number one as a writer
and it was his first number one as an
artist and he was at big loud and I was
writing other songs for other people at
big loud and that's when they kind of
came to me and and they were just like
if you know do you want to do the artist
thing
wow yeah and that was 20 it was 2018.
damn so that's not that long no it dude
it feels like a time has flown by but it
also feels like forever ago but like I
didn't I was super apprehensive about it
like well most of that was covered
yeah what a lot of it yeah I mean when I
really my [__] finally kind of started
going is when 2020 happened
um but I was I saw like what Morgan was
going through and it's not a bad thing
it's it's great but like you if you're
if your [__] like pops off like it
that your life changes you you
understand I mean like your life changes
forever and and I just didn't know like
I had an offer on the table and I sat
with it for months because I didn't know
if I wanted to to do it I was I'd had
some success as a writer and I was like
man this you get to go write a [__]
song and then go play golf every day or
something and and uh I just got done
reading The Alchemist and that book it
talks about opportunities and Omens and
stuff like that a lot and so I had that
in my head because it it kept kind of
getting brought up of like you know like
are you gonna sign this record deal and
blah blah blah and then I finally just
said I I'm gonna do it because I didn't
want to regret it later you know having
you turned it down or whatever
I think it's awesome that you that you
did choose that I mean you know like
Mississippi has a lot of great writers
yeah you know I mean over time some of
the greatest writers are from
Mississippi and uh yeah Eudora Welty I
think he's from Mississippi right yeah I
think so
um dude and then you've got Elvis oh
yeah Robert Johnson who arguably created
rock and roll with the blues
um this is is does he have us does his
son did his son play music too I think
so I should know that but I don't
um
but yeah and it's it's nice to see Mrs
kind of like you know because people a
lot of times especially in the South
they put an artist onto a state you know
it's good to see Louisiana getting a guy
it's good to see Mississippi yeah you
know have a musician you know like that
uh people can get behind and a guy that
has his own point of view and stuff like
that I think it's because also a place
needs that you know there needs to be a
young man in Mississippi right now who
loves your music and then he's gonna
learn he might not even realize right
now you're from Mississippi and then in
five years he will have no way he's for
I could do that yeah so because that's
how things happen absolutely man we had
are you familiar with Marty Stewart uh
he's a big Bluegrass guy pull him up
please and he had he had a uh he had a
couple of hits in just a regular country
format in the 90s but he's a really
famous Roots like Bluegrass guy and uh
he there he is he is from Philadelphia
Mississippi and so when I was a kid he
was the [__] and so exactly what you're
saying like I always had that in my mind
of like well somebody from Philly went
and did it you know and he really made
it I mean he's very very respected in
the country he's really big in the Opry
and like all that you know and I've
certainly heard his name before so it
was inspiring man that was like uh I
knew it was like exactly what you said
like it can be done and that gave me the
courage to move up here and give it a
shot well there's a part of your brain
that you don't even know that's working
that it's like okay that's in my head
that that's possible yeah and until that
little thing until that little coin gets
put in your bank yeah your brain doesn't
really have that as a as as part of its
account yeah you're not like hyper
focused on that it's just you're
something no it's just yeah your
subconscious like oh this can happen in
your subconscious that you know it just
starts to be part of the uh your assets
you know in the background you're like
oh then eventually it can happen my
favorite comedian one of the reasons I
believe that I got into comedy and
storytelling myself um
my best friend Scott he's a uh his dad
is from Jax and his family's from
Jackson Mississippi yeah cool and
I would go up there and he would play
Jerry Clower for me oh come on dude
speaking my language bro he would play
Jerry Cloud knock him out John dude
like from Yazoo City in Mississippi
that's it and and I was like oh my God
like this guy like
he's a it just it's amazing what he's
doing and like that that this is a
possible thing and I think hearing that
to this day has had a big effect on the
fact that um that I got into
storytelling and then I like it or that
I believed maybe that I could do it
um do you think like was he kind of the
first guy that really
based his comedy around southern
ideals and stuff
I think he was a really
well he sounded very Southern right but
I think he was probably just a good
Storyteller and he had a lot of that
like um the lead betters you know like
he named people in his neighborhood and
characters so when you were listening to
him you start he had this world was
being real yeah yeah yeah and so I think
I I that was fascinating to me because
I'm seriously because you talk a lot
about people from your hometown so yeah
that was an influence or whatever yeah
no I think it probably had a lot to do
with it you know but it was funny
because yeah my best friend's dad he
said yeah you got to listen to this guy
you'll love him and he put him on I just
I couldn't believe it was a thing you
know
and then man that's awesome dude I
haven't really heard Jerry Clower in a
long time that I remember my childhood
been playing him too everybody knew his
bits right oh yeah it was really cool
yeah and you got and there's there's
video you see him performing he always
wore this kind of like loud red outfit
right he was a big dude too right yeah
and he was a Dr he had a cocaine problem
for a while and he ended up being a
pastor I think towards the end of it I
didn't know that his wife still lives in
Mississippi but he passed not like that
long ago right 10 15 years ago or
something like that
yeah I'm not sure when he passed I would
say 10 yeah it sounded like about 10 or
15 years ago yeah
um but one day I was getting out of my
car at the mall and this guy comes
running up and he goes hey man uh I've
heard you say that my grandfather is
your favorite comedian and it was his
grandson here Jonathan Clower yeah here
here no way dude do you look like him
that's pretty cool is he a big dude I
mean he was young so it's hard to be
like I didn't want to [__] you know
dude that's really cool Nashville
put him in old clothes and see how he
looked you know he didn't have like the
old like puffed up it would have been
crazy
he was born like that
um so how did you get over to so at that
point so you're starting to write you're
in school
um how do you get over to Mississippi
State that's where you went right no I
didn't do that dude this is my biggest
and I understand like if I didn't move
up here when I did like my life would be
completely different but that's like my
biggest life regret is that both my
parents went to State we were a
Mississippi State family but I moved to
Nashville when I was 19. I went to one
semester at a junior college called East
Central Community College in Decatur
Mississippi but uh no I didn't go to
state I actually went to uh Middle
Tennessee down here in Murfreesboro
and you got your degree from there yeah
I did yeah wow commercial songwriting
dang really yeah so you just went and
took a class on it yeah I mean it's like
a poor man's Belmont you know what I
mean yeah um like all the kids all the
belt the kids that didn't get into
Belmont which is like you know the big
music I mean it literally sits at the
end of Music Row down here
um but yeah I mean and the songwriting
class was like whatever and I've said
this before and I feel kind of
uncomfortable because I know there's
people watching it probably that go to
MTSU there but like when I was there it
was like there was no filter so it was
like a bunch of people that just weren't
very good and so like it was like okay
today we're going to learn about writing
a verse and it's there's got to be
structure and each line has to rhyme
it's just stuff that you like most
people knew but there were a couple kids
in there that like got it you know what
I mean like you were you like you had to
play a song you wrote every week and
they'd critique it and talk about it and
this and that the other yeah and and
there was some people in there were
horrible and but there were some kids in
there that were really good but you
could tell like that was what I took
away was like the people that had it had
it but you can't like learn it like you
can't in my opinion like I don't know if
you could like say man I owe all of my
songwriting success to the songwriting
class at MTSU because it's like
songwriters it's like any other form of
writing it's like everybody has that
weird internal voice and that's how they
write and stuff and I feel like people
are just born with that
yeah I think you can hone things yeah
and you can like fine-tune them you can
Whittle them right you know you could
put a little bit of you know you could
put something in a crust you know you
could put a icing on something yeah but
you got to have something you gotta have
the the natural kind of thing I think
but I learned a lot about the industry
there like record deals and Publishing I
mean I learned a ton about all that
stuff and like even recording studio
stuff like I got all of that all of that
stuff from MTSU yeah and then the first
time you hear those things in business
it's not the first time you've ever
heard them you know so it's interesting
how like some people know I took a
comedy class right so I went to I was in
uh I was out in Los Angeles you know and
everybody was just you know it was when
you first get out there that's a lot of
like kind of per like every
people like don't have agents and
managers will sign you but just because
they're damn pedophiles or something you
know it's like they'll try to get you
out to dinner and they they give you a
ride home and they're squeezing on your
leg or something you know yeah asking if
you got any leftovers on you or
something like you know just some slimy
[__] what are you even talking about you
know I don't have any leftovers but it's
like yeah it's just a lot of pervs out
there but um eventually I found you know
I said no to all that and then I got
into a comedy class and the best thing
about it was I thought I was probably in
my head I thought it was better than the
class maybe in a weird way or I didn't
but it made you at the end of the class
you had to get on stage after six you
know and then I realized as a class one
some people were better joke writers and
they were better like organ they're
keeping their stuff or I just came in
with a little bit of an attitude I think
but at the end you got on stage so how
long was it how long do you have to go
for it was six weeks and it was probably
the actual performance oh three minutes
okay damn so they didn't give you you
had to like you had to give it
everything you got then oh yeah dude and
it was like and the first week like at
the end we're gonna do a three minute
format you're like I got that and then
like the day of I mean you're you know
you're losing it yeah you know people
are just damn you know
just losing it jumping off of really
small buildings not hurting themselves
but just you know yeah just practicing
it because they can't handle it exactly
but
um it got yeah but then we got on stage
and that was the thing that was the
breaker it was like for you guys having
to have a song at the end of the week
it's like yeah that's the thing where
it's like okay
because if I don't get on stage then I
don't know if I ever get on stage can
you do it right can you actually do it
right yeah and once you get that first
can you do it once you get that first
like Open Mic or I'm gonna write a song
and play it in front of other people
right once you get through that first
time
everything changes yeah because then you
have a real clear idea on if you're
capable of it or what part of it you're
capable of the most yeah and that's all
contingent on your audience too right in
a way because you don't know if you
killed it or if you did a good job
unless somebody tells you people that
you know you can trust that's a good
point but I think you get a feeling as
to okay maybe I loved writing it maybe I
didn't love being up there maybe I mean
you're just getting more information
yeah you know it's crazy that the the
how much how little information you have
before that first step
almost with anything yeah that's really
true man you know it's like very true
especially for getting on any type of
stage it's like you just don't you know
yes he's gonna throw into the wolves in
that moment right yeah but but right
after that you're like all right you
know
yeah and then you get into like
immediately I I feel that like you can
immediately be like your brain starts
ticking on like what you could have done
better and like how to make it better
but you don't know that until you do it
right yeah and it's so crazy the
difference between I didn't do it yet
until I just did it yeah you'll come off
be like and suddenly you'll be like next
time I'm gonna do it this way and you're
like what am I saying next time that
means I want to do it again it's like
just the little information that you get
from taking that first step dude that's
such a cool Snowball Effect too because
it just it gets better and better and
like you're constantly critiquing
yourself and telling yourself next time
which is manifesting that you're gonna
it's gonna get bigger and better and all
that yes true yeah that's interesting it
is man
um when you write a song like so you
guys write you and Laney wrote wait in
the truck no so I so she she did not she
did not did not write it okay yes so you
write the song with other writers right
okay yep um
just it's like going to work and you
just you know go in a room and throw out
your ideas and sit around and write a
song now say you walk in a room right
and you see the other writers in there
is there sometimes you're like all right
I'm gonna put a certain ideas and
sometimes I'm keeping some in totally oh
yeah oh dude like if you're this is like
if you have a like ball and ass badass
idea like I'll sit on that until I know
I'm in a room because if you throw it
out especially in Nashville like La it
can be a little greasier where like
people will take back ideas but you just
don't do that really in Nashville and
like like uh it's not his dog eat dog
let's just put it that way as it is in
L.A and
but like I'll wait until I'm with some
of my buddies or people that will
completely grasp a cool idea so you know
you're gonna nail it because I've made
the mistake of throwing out a really
good title with some people that could
that just couldn't latch onto it as well
as maybe other people could and you just
kind of ruined the idea and then you
can't really write it again or you're an
[__] right at least other people are
attached to it and that sort of thing
and you get then then that's when like
you'll you know then if you did write it
10 years later then you got to add these
people because they were there when you
know and they're like well I said that
line and you used that in this song too
but yeah there's definitely times like
waiting the truck's a perfect example so
Hunter Phelps is like one of my best
friends and I wrote that with him and
Jordan Schmidt who's also one of my best
friends I'm pointing that way because
Jordan lives right down the road okay
um and Hunter and I kind of came up with
that idea together and we knew Jordan
was a really incredible writer and that
that was the time to bring that idea out
and ride it with somebody definitely
that's wild man that's cool yeah
interesting because I guess in the
beginning you might go in and just put
all your eggs out there and the other
two people one of them shows up hung
over one of them you know is pre you
know not prep could be I just found out
they're pregnant right yeah [__]
ruined yeah their day is wrecked yeah
exactly
uh and then you're like damn man you
just don't get it to fruition yeah and
it dude it breaks my heart when I have a
great idea and you
because then you're just like
[__] like that that that I mean really
if to get into the technical or the not
to be vain or not vain but materialistic
but you're like I just missed out on
like two hundred thousand dollars
because I had a hit idea and I just
ruined it on on these people it happens
dude you just kind of beat yourself up
about it and like
this and that some people even go home
and completely rewrite the idea and make
it better and be like send it back to
the people you wrote it with and you're
like I like this you guys can be on the
song but I completely rewrote the song
or whatever does that happen sometimes
where somebody will write it to other
people are in the room and they get a
part of the credit and that's that
yeah the rule in Nashville is drop a
word or say a word take a third you know
like
it doesn't matter if you're having a bad
day and that there's like
it always evens itself out because like
you go into a room with two other people
and one of the guys sits over there and
doesn't say a word he's still on the
song he still has a third of the song
like freaking boo Wordly over there yeah
right Bradley yeah like uh sitting over
there like [__] yeah I'm just not
saying a damn word just staring up or
something but then there's times where
you might not be on your A-game and
somebody else two of the other guys are
guys or girls are killing it and yeah
you know you it's just like a Nashville
rule I know in La like they have lawyers
they have people like sitting in on
rights like paying attention to who said
what and then they like get in and they
try to like negotiate who contributed
the most and that's like the percentage
they get that hasn't made it here yet I
hope it doesn't miss sounds stressful
ah it ruins everything La will ruin
anything
are you still out there do you still
haven't you still live out there at all
yeah I probably spent about almost three
I would say almost four months maybe all
right out of the year out there because
I have to practice out there I can't
really practice comedy in Nashville yeah
so zany's is that the only spot here
yeah that's kind of surprising I mean
it's good for them I guess because they
have like uh they if I mean it's like
that until you until you you're bigger
than that right and then you do like the
rhyming or something right yeah
so we could do other places yeah it's
like but if I want to practice you know
like in LA you can probably do three
spots a night
is that like Comedy Store and stuff like
Improv Comedy Store there's a place
called The Bourbon Room that's really
popping
um West Side comedy there's a I mean you
could do five in a night if you wanted
to but at a certain point just driving
around like perform you're not really
learning anything you know you just like
show up and and see the guy that runs
the thing and you're like y'all got a
spot for me or do you schedule an
advance no on Mondays usually putting
your avails ah so that I mean you can
someplace you could stop in and they'll
let you get up if you have a certain
level of I guess
he probably is a better term
but I don't know that always feels
uncomfortable to me like I always say
you're crash in a party yeah a little
bit and it feels like it's not your you
know somebody else drove up there yeah
they might have a couple children they
might be expecting to get home I don't
want to wreck that guys yeah or you know
I don't want to have him get home 30
minutes later yeah it's you know that's
nice it's like just out of respect right
it's like showing up to somebody's show
and then somebody pointing you out and
then you get up there and play for an
hour and steal the show or something
right like if you want to do one so you
know but but but yeah I think yeah so
that kind of thing is a little bit
uncomfortable kind of uh so I would
rather I like to and I like to know in
advance when I'm gonna have to go go to
work yeah you know because now it's it
is more like going to work
um is it interesting does that start to
feel like that for you like in the
beginning that
it was a lot more of like this is fun
and it's still fun yeah but one it once
it becomes your work it becomes your
work yeah yeah definitely I mean
man I would almost argue and say that
the the more into it I get like the the
the more the years have gone by the the
more fun it feels and the less because
when you're if you just start out man
and you're like you've got a new brand
new single you're doing like radio tour
and I mean you're grinding so hard and
you're playing shitty shows for people
that don't you're either opening for
somebody and the crowd is not there for
you so they have no [__] idea who you
are
so but then the more you're established
I feel like I mean it it still feels
like work it's just a crazy job but it's
it's I think it's more fun the more like
you know success you have which I guess
that that makes you know that's obvious
but no it's not obvious really I don't
think
I think it's interesting because it's
like
yeah I don't know if I I guess there's
different ways to look at it or
different ways that it kind of happened
in the way you perceived it yeah
because I think some people would
say that it was more fun
in those other moments yeah and I guess
in some ways it is more it's like
you don't know what's gonna happen yeah
that's true well that's true like it
there's so much left to wonder like
what's going to come of that you mean
right or what the other side of the coin
can look like a little yeah so I guess
maybe fun isn't the overall word that
we're kind of
looking at it's like it's all fun but
some of it's
thrilling more thrilling in a way or
yeah I don't know I mean I'm just trying
to figure it out and today's one of
those days where I'm not figuring it out
that good you know but that's okay man
um
but yeah it definitely there's things
that are more
well there's more Intrigue I feel like
but I don't know because then you get
different opportunities you're like oh
God this is what this feels like you
know it's like yeah I think it's all it
kind of comes in like not waves but even
levels right like that's a good word you
know because then you have a you have
like a big record and then then you're
kind of like new to a newer scene of
more of a higher level you know and and
then there's more wonder and all that
and then like you blow up again or have
another big moment and I don't know I
feel like it could be kind of tiered but
it's all relative it's all the same
situation but just at different levels
of success maybe I think that's a good
way to say it I remember uh going to you
guys's show at the
in Nashville Redstone at Bridgestone
yeah and I remember seeing the uh arrows
on the flutter taped on the floor where
the where the artists go and go up and
like you know because it's dark back
there yeah yeah everything really dark
and I remember thinking oh man how cool
you know I've always wanted to be like
see what the rock star sees you know
like stage and all that kind of stuff
yeah it was just like and I have my own
backstage at shows and they're it's
different you know it's just with comedy
it's a lot different it's really subdued
it's just you're sitting back there yeah
I was gonna say there's probably not
it's not all hustle and bustle because
there's not it's like the production's
not like a country like or any like a
concert oh there's nobody in a damn bum
a vape off of you yeah yeah yeah like
you and your do you have a tour manager
yeah you got a tour manager a couple
other comedians yeah yeah and it's wild
it's like quiet and more chill it's dead
quiet yeah that's kind of crazy yeah and
so so it's totally different to be back
there in you guys environment is like
people walking around oh yeah especially
like you call it like a Nashville show
it's like [__] chaos back there it's
just but in the best way like there's
it's just exciting and there's people
everywhere and like other country stars
and [__] walking around yeah it was cool
that's when Ronnie Dunn came out and
played yes that's right God he can I
didn't realize he could oh dude he's a
legend I mean I knew he could sing but I
just didn't know it was like that yeah
uh dude he's a people a lot of people
say that he's like the his the most the
most or one of the most iconic voices in
the country he's a damn wind instrument
dude he's like damn my God this [__]
man flew hang him outside on your
grandmother's porch yeah
that's what the damn birds eat off of
him did you imagine dude a [__]
Ronnie Dunn wind chime dude just every
time it was like every time it's
actually a great idea that'd be [__]
awesome if we can make it so that when
the wind went through it it sounded just
like him yeah and then have three notes
in harmony you know like wind chimes do
yeah
you know I'm trying to keep it I'm
trying to stay wigged up baby keep that
hair going and keep it tight
that's what keeps helps me do that's
right keeps offers a simple affordable
and stress-free way to keep your hair
they do it via expert recommended hair
loss treatments personalized treatment
plans that are recommended by a licensed
medical provider and delivered straight
to your door that's the thing man
your homies your own hair it's your own
dang it's that just that beauty wig just
knocking at your door like a damn just
like a damn [__] skin cap baby come on
they have 24 7 care and support and
they're low cost the treatment plans are
affordable typically half the cost of
Pharmacy prices
remember prevention is key with hair
loss
and treatments can take four to six
months to see results so you want to act
fast
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to
k-e-e-p-s.com slash Theo to receive your
first month of treatment for free that's
k-e-e-p-s.com slash Theo to get your
first month free k e e p s.com slash
Theo
be smart don't start
kick the habit put it out before it puts
you out
all phrases that we've heard a hundred
times yet we continue to have bad habits
our new sponsor fume is on a mission to
accelerate Humanity's breakup from the
bad habits that consume far too many of
us
fume is a natural diffusive device that
uses plants and Behavioral Science to
help you trade out your negative habit
for a positive one
fume is not a vape it's a non-electric
device designed to transform your
negative habits instead of PODS filled
with potentially harmful chemicals like
a vape fume uses cores infused with
plants like peppermint and cinnamon for
delicious natural flavors I gotta say
fume is nice it's nice to go to
something when you need something when
you have that moment we're like I need
something it's nice to go to something
that's not going to hurt you
the easiest way to stop a bad habit is
to switch to a positive one head to try
fume
t-r-y-f-u-m.com and use code Theo to
save 10 off when you get the journey
pack today the journey pack comes with
three unique flavors and the new version
2 fume to help kick start your positive
habits that's try f-u-m and use code
Theo to save an additional 10 off on
your order today yeah that was fun man
and who oh I was there oh your parents
were there yeah my mom is actually
they're having some work done they live
here at the house and so she I was
walking out the door she was like where
are you going I told her I was coming
over here and she's like oh I love him
because I forgot y'all had met there
y'all met right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I got to meet your folks there and um
and who will yeah like oh Baker Mayfield
was there yeah he was there and like
yeah that was so random dude it was
random Jason Jason worth uh uh um uh I
think it's Jason worth baseball player
there was a bunch of like athletes there
it was yeah it was a bizarre group of
people man it was an interesting group
that was fun though Ernest was on yep
yeah that was great man was that there
was three nights one of them I came the
first night Thursday night to me I
thought Thursday and Friday were the
best it was Thursday night St Patty's or
was that Friday I can't remember one of
them was St Patty's Day and I just
remember how drunk the whole crowd was
it was like I could see it from all the
way at the top like people were falling
over and stuff oh that might have been
sad I don't oh yeah I don't think when I
left I remember seeing people doing St
Patty's stuff it might have been it
might have been might have been Saturday
yeah
um
is there a night that you guys like to
is there a night when you feel like the
shows are better a day is there a show
that give me that day and time okay that
a country for show or that that a
performance a musical performance is the
best
Friday nights
usually in the summer
because Thursday night a lot of people
have to go to work so they're there and
they'll stay up late but they're not
gonna they're not gonna party and then
Saturday night a lot of people have to
go to church especially in the country
crowd Friday night it's like I just got
off of work and I don't have [__] to do
tomorrow that's like that's the one
every time even if you do you can feel
it especially when you if you do three
nights at one venue uh-huh you you can
see the difference between Thursday
Friday and Saturday it's pretty crazy
and the Saturday crowd's like more tired
and hungover you know what I mean
they're all good but like Friday night
nothing ever beats Friday night it's the
best damn yeah because for comedy it's
different Friday night is the toughest
night really why do you think so I think
it's because people have been working
they get off and I don't think they want
to be kind of still in a space where
they have to sit and kind of listen and
pay attention yes I think their
attention is a little burned out they
either want to [__] rip their dick oh
you know or not they're somebody's there
yeah yeah yeah they want to rip a tit
off or whatever and get a damn Michelob
in them or they want to
um
or they want to uh chill out yeah but I
don't think they want that middle ground
well I wonder why that's
but it's notoriously the word Steve
Martin quit performing touring on Friday
nights because that totally I think but
because if you go out and you're just
waiting Thursday to Saturday I think
it's just kind of a low but he said he
quit performing because Friday night
really it's that big of it's that big of
a difference
I wonder why I mean I guess
I don't know it's crazy because I guess
you don't have to pay attention at a
concert this is super rt4 I guess you
feel music more than like you actually
pay attention to yeah you know so maybe
that's a little bit more of a release
than feeling like having to sit and
focus on something maybe I don't know
yeah I don't know it's interesting that
is interesting sometimes it stands up I
think in the in the end it gets it gets
in your head that Friday's gonna be you
know might not be but then I don't know
half the time I feel like I can't really
tell the difference so dude what other
if you take Louisiana out of the
equation what's your favorite City to
play in oh dang dude anywhere in Texas
is good really Texas is [__] good
dude but then Portland some of my
biggest Crowds Are like Portland
um Australia oh dude I'm going in like a
month I've never been oh bro I'm so
excited it's like you know they started
it it was all criminals dude yeah they
sent them down there that's right from
from like the UK area right so it's
awesome yeah dude you know that Georgia
our Georgia uh was the same thing thing
really was like Australia for Americans
and they would send uh and you can fact
check me but I'm because I could be
wrong but I'm pretty sure it was a place
where if you went bankrupt or committed
a crime they would send you down to
Georgia because Georgia is one of the I
think one of the 13 colonies it's one of
the original if not it's like it was
very early and they would send it down
there to uh send you down there to like
restart down there from jail to Georgia
let's see that hey I think you had it
there bub
zoom in on that if you don't mind please
18th century Georgia was really just
King George's penal colony right can you
zoom in a little bit more
um
as conceived by its founder James
Oglethorpe and his trustees in London
Georgia was expressly built on the
theory of work release
um and it's
they convinced King George
the overcrowding in prisons
uh it's fair to say that scores are
recently released
people of the king's House of
Corrections were among the colonists huh
there you go damn is that crazy
well the years
this might go for the whole STC because
Louisiana they said it if um it was like
criminals and prostitutes from France
really it settled like in New Orleans no
in France or like if you want to marry a
prostitute we'll give you oh [__] land
in Louisiana
I just tweeted something about it or no
I saw I just saw something the original
colony of Georgia for example was
founded by James Oglethorpe who
originally intended to use prisoners
taken largely from debtors prisons
creating a debtors colony where the
prisoners could learn trades and work
off their debts wow dude isn't that
crazy she had people over there that
were just work doing a trade to work off
a debt that was in England that's crazy
yeah isn't that wild
but then the craziest part would be
after the American Revolution or after
we've won the beat England and I guess
right in the war that those people were
just like oh I don't know anybody
anything yeah
so then they were just free that's
correct they were just there
huh that seems like Georgia a little
yeah dude
um what is something I was thinking
about this what is something that
uh had you met Laney before you guys got
together to make that song oh yeah I I
uh so that tour I was talking about
Morgan brought me on that tour I said
800 to 2000 people Laney was first of
three uh just acoustic so she was the
acoustic uh opener and then I was second
and Morgan was third and so I met her
then we did that was like
39 shows or something so we she was and
that's I really got to know her then she
was on the first half of that tour and
got to really know her then yeah she's I
love she's like a sister to me dude she
is salt of the earth yeah oh she seems
really really I mean she's interesting
beautiful exciting just authentic man
just a real deal yeah she just yeah she
sounds like
I mean you just want to climb down her
throat and just damn just being just
ready to live in it yeah yeah just get a
damn you know get you a little oven or
something in there and just stay in
there yeah make sure triple chairs yeah
dude yeah it's like she just she sounds
like a home yeah that's a good way to
put it wow
um
and she sounds yeah she just sounds
really this is so powerful I really
enjoy getting to spend time with her I
was thinking what is something that
people wait in the truck for
um
their sonic order
okay definitely Sonic uh they're like
they're drug dealers show up maybe okay
drugs and Sonic yeah
um
oh their wife anywhere their wife oh
yeah especially if you're like if you're
like the kind that's like I'm gonna go
wait in the truck sorry you know and
they're honking kind of doing which was
every dad I feel like oh yeah when we
were like and even like I mean you're
young and people when we were growing up
it was like every day I was like I'm
gonna wait yeah I'm gonna be out of here
I heard a story about George Jones and
he like got tired of waiting on
um his current the wife that he died
with I can't remember her name uh I
should know that but at that one time
he he wouldn't wait on her so he went
and sat in the car and laid on the horn
and she came out in her underwear and
got in the car and he was so fixated on
going wherever they were going he drove
all the way down the road and didn't
realize she was she was pulling one on
him because she was like well [__] you
then well I'll go wherever we're going
I'm going in my underwear if you can't
wait and even went like five miles down
the road until he realized that she was
in her underwear and turned around and
came back
yeah that was always a thing I'm gonna
wait in the truck and you would just see
dads out there just
shaking their head what about like
you're like a little brother when your
Big Brother's like at baseball practice
you know like that type of deal oh yeah
I'm a Sit you would see that brother's
always just leaning yeah open on the
open window yep and then somebody would
come up and just like bang on the window
scare the [__] out of them yeah yeah
um what else do people wait for yeah
drugs for sure dude I uh waiting for
drugs is always scary it was always like
dude always always I always had to wait
what was the [__] deal why don't drug
yeah drug dealers are not punctual
no they're not dude even like weed
before weed was legal like I would have
panic attacks dude like he'd be like
show up here at three and I'd be like
all right cool and then and then like
dude it would be like 305 and I'm like
but you're like I don't want to piss my
drug dealer you know what I mean like I
don't want to piss my guy off but you're
like where the [__] are you at did you
get arrested like
are they are like in my mind it was like
okay the cops got him and they're like
all right go do the drug deal so we can
bust the guy like I have all right you
know dude I remember this guy I told us
one time he's like yeah meet me at this
time so we get there it's like a huge in
the middle of this Kmart parking lot
right so we're like we'll [__] pick
up Corners they're behind it it was just
the worst idea right so we so we don't
we're like I remember we drove around
like just around the middle for a while
like I guess we might want to go in it
was like if we went into the middle we
were in trouble but it was like we were
just scoping I thought it'd be less
suspicious to just make like a bunch of
laps around the parking lot oh dude the
worst yeah I remember one time we got
some weed to sell it right and it was
like we're so excited right we get this
weed and the second we got it we're like
oh we're going to [__] jail dude
right so we're so scared we're in the
driveway we finally ended up just giving
the [__] away to a guy down the street
dude and just ended up working the uh
the payment off
was it like a cop or was it like was it
like teenager a lot of like an ounce or
something no no I would say it was
probably yeah maybe a QP I think yeah
damn good hahaha damn dude gave it away
that was a good day for the guy you gave
it to though
and maybe he saw that in us maybe said
oh these fear babies over here and we'll
[__] get that yeah he might have was
it a stranger or somebody you knew
somebody we knew okay
it was fun though
um
all right so you get in attuned you get
out here yeah how do you get that first
hit you think dude it's I have it's a
crazy story I got my first publishing
deal
and what is a publishing deal for people
that don't know so it's so if you're
just a songwriter in Nashville you sign
there's time if you drive up down music
Road there's like 50 or probably more
publishing companies and they sign
songwriters and the the point is they
pay songwriters a salary to write for
that company and they also they have
people that work for the company that
schedule the rights for the songwriter
they pitch the songs to artists that the
songwriters turn in you know that type
of thing oh so you get a deal with a
Publishing House
or a publishing company company and then
you're kind of like one of their batters
in their box yeah exactly wow yeah and
and like you know
a lot of times
I've seen like you know [__] Joe Blow
nobody signs with a pub deal and then he
blows up or signs with the publisher
company and then he blows up and has a
bunch of hits as a rider well then
suddenly that publishing company is on
the map because people are going to want
to sign there so they can write with
this dude you know what I mean and
that's how people that's how big loud
you know big loud started as a
Publishing Company Craig Wiseman signed
like four writers and it was like Rodney
Clawson Sarah Buxton Chris Tompkins uh
and a few others and they all blew the
[__] up and they and so that just boomed
big loud and then and with along with
Craig who also was a big hit Rider and
so then they were able to really have a
legit publishing company and sign a
bunch of writers because people wanted
to be in that camp because they were the
guys writing all the hits okay so then
how does a big loud get guys like Morgan
and you and Ernest so once they you know
so they're doing well people know their
name right as just as a publishing
company and so then Craig Wiseman and uh
I think at that point Seth England and
them decided to start a record label uh
and so that's you know when they started
big loud records and then they
said well let's go find an artist to try
to develop and then they went and found
Chris Lane and they had a hit on Chris
Lane and FGL was in that because because
they signed FGL to a publishing company
but they also managed them but but their
record label is a big machine but they
had Chris Lane and then you know they
broke Chris Lane and then they went and
they've got
um
I don't even know who like the next
would have been but anyway then they
found they found Morgan and they just
like catch word like Morgan was on The
Voice and then he had you know worried
had gotten out that he had been coming
into town and doing stuff and so they
were like let's let's have a meeting
with this Morgan Wallen kid and they
reach out to Morgan and Morgan plays
them a couple songs
they're like we like your voice seem
like you know we could work well with
you they sign into a recording you know
it's just constantly growing in that
whole deal and then guys like you at
that point are friends already with
Morgan you see that he's there and that
excites you guys yeah yeah I mean like I
met Morgan part of it yeah yes exactly
and and like uh and especially like uh
Florida Georgia Line and those guys like
they were all in that big loud camp and
so that draws people into that and but
uh I met Morgan when the way I talk was
like at I think it died at like number
30 which is crazy to think about because
it's such a still like a big hit for him
but it it died at like number 30 at
radio and I wrote with him around that
time and uh for the first time and I was
just a big fan of that song and his
voice and I was just like this kid's
really good and so he came over to the
house but I've lived in an apartment
over here and and we wrote and hit it
instantly hit it off and you know the
rest is history bam but with my I so my
publisher to this day his name is Dennis
McCoskey
and he grew up in Philadelphia
Pennsylvania but his mom oh really from
Philadelphia Mississippi
and his mom is my grandfather's
aunt
so and I knew and so Dennis in the 80s
lived in L.A he's not grandfather's Aunt
so so Dennis and my grandfather are
first cousins they're they shared moms
sisters you know what I mean and when
Dennis Dennis in the 80s was a big hit
songwriter in LA and his claim to fame
he's done a bunch of other amazing
things but his biggest claim to fame is
he wrote maniac
I'm in the 80s exactly yeah and
so growing up I knew I had this cool
cousin that was like a songwriter but I
didn't know like I knew he lived in
Nashville at this point but I didn't
know and he's an older guy he's like
late 60s maybe early 70s and um
so I was in college and I was writing
songs videoing them on my webcam dude
and putting them on like YouTube and
[__] and then sharing them over but dude
yeah right I know right uh and he wrote
on my Facebook wall and what my Facebook
wall dude and was like I like you seem
like you're doing good like come by the
house with a bigger pervert Yeah Dude
dude that was that's like back then this
was [__] this was like but if a man
writes on your Facebook wall you seem
like you're doing good come by the house
sometime to anybody that didn't know the
situation I could see how that would be
yes yeah
he signed me and then I mean well he it
took like years but but it was a cool
thing because like if it was a family
thing but I didn't really know him and
then he reached out and so we've now and
now he and I are very close so but it
felt like it was supposed to happen when
some of those other pieces are kind of
built into the background in the Stars
especially when it's family stuff yeah
you kind of put those pieces together
yeah
um what about uh
what about so tell me a little bit more
about that publishing house so how does
that work so people get some writers get
signed to a publishing house right they
start writing yeah and then they're on
salary yeah but if one of them does well
and creates a song then they start to
make money from the song yeah but only
these days only if the song uh gets
played on the radio
um so
you have what's called mechanical
royalties
and that is royalties that are paid to
the song If it sells copies so like for
instance like on Morgan's last record
the big record that created a lot of
mechanical royalties because it sold
really well right so but but when you
sign your first publishing deal most
first publishing deals called a baby
deal
uh
you you as a rider you don't get control
of your mechanical royalties that goes
to the publisher and the publishing
company oh wow and it's just something
that's been around for a long time so so
even if you had a song that blew up on
Tick Tock or that sold or streamed like
crazy on Apple music or Spotify or
whatever
um you wouldn't see any of that money
the only way that young songwriters
really make money because most of their
salaries are like if you sign up first
publishing deal it's like 40 Grand
that's that's really good like you're
doing really good so it it really for a
year for usually they're like four four
years three or four yeah so 40 Grand
over three or four years no oh sorry yes
it's 40 Grand a year for the term is
like three or four years got it but you
only make money if if you have a hit on
the radio so like
anything especially for a young Rider
top 20 and better is you'll make a
life-changing amount of money right you
know what I mean like is that the one
you were talking about early you can
make a couple hundred thousand dollars
and number one you will wow depending on
how many riders because if it's split
you know if it's a six way you're gonna
make less you're gonna make half of what
you'd make if it was a three-way and
that kind of thing but um
but uh yeah so the radio pays out a lot
of money and that's where that's where
songwriters get paid and that's through
Pros which is paid
wait what's it what does it stand for
paid royalty organization
is that right yeah I think so and and
they they collect money from the radio
stations and then they in return pay the
writers for having hits on the radio
ah it was tricky man it's hard to get a
song on the radio like it's it's a it's
so hard it's I worked well you know one
of my jobs that I had I was a tour
manager for uh Josh Kelly I don't know
if I ever told you that or not really
yeah Georgia Clay uh just like that
George and Clay yeah was it that time
baby dude you're amazing yeah yeah oh
Josh's man I didn't know that you tm'd
him yeah it did when was that we went
around the whole country dude we would
go to all the radio stations and I would
go in in the morning and be like
just can't leave yeah you know yeah and
get the coffee and the donuts and you
know get people fired up and stuff and
Josh would come in with his get to you
paint a picture on the wall yeah man it
was awesome whoa this was I don't know
this is probably 17 years ago maybe or
something like that oh wow but we went
around
we went to I think every radio station I
mean we went to a lot of the bigger
radio stations that radio tour game man
so I didn't realize until you were
saying that I kind of forgot about it
but yeah yeah we would go in and you try
and agrees not grease these people you
wanted to get them excited about an
artist yeah of course you know yeah and
they see so many of them that like what
can you do you know like let's yeah
tomorrow you know Jason Mraz is bringing
crab legs
exactly dude yeah dude man dude it's
it's hard man just sit in a room and
they're just they're looking at you like
yeah what are you doing here you know I
did not know that though that's crazy
yeah Josh Kelly is one of the most
talented guys out there and
yeah I just feel I feel grateful I got
to be just even a little bitty part of
his career that was fun man it was
interesting but that's why I learned
about kind of and that's when radio was
still even more it was a bigger deal
yeah 20 15 years ago yeah now they've
all a lot of them have been kind of
Consolidated now yeah I mean streaming
is just streaming is like
it's taking over a lot of that market
for sure yeah
what was I thinking about uh
did I sorry do you see that thing with
the governor
the um Tennessee yeah I don't I'm not
sure it was like
the governor of Tennessee
um
brought crab legs
no this Tennessee governor of peers have
dressed and oh there remember did you
see this thing you're trying to make it
so in Tennessee you couldn't
they don't want people performing get
into the article man if you don't mind
criminalizing drag performances in
public
yeah my dad he recently passed Bill
criminalizing drag performances in
public and in front of children so they
want to stop by guess like drag perform
they don't want performances that could
influence I guess a child's sexuality
maybe or
um but then this is the governor right
and they found a picture of him in a
powder puff oh no way and so that's what
they're saying well they say look here
you are you dragging out oh boy you know
so they found this a picture of him in
high school man but it looks like
they're gonna try to pass this law
which is kind of wild you know yeah I
mean let's just let people do what they
want well I think it's like it almost
seems like it's more of a parent's thing
like if you're taking your child to
something yeah where where would you
where are you going to be that your
child's gonna see a drag show right
without the parent gun like a child
child yeah you know without the parent
going dude I remember in we went to like
a prom or something dance and they had
this restaurant in the French Quarter
New Orleans and it was uh
it was all drag queens in there yeah and
dude they kept getting like they were
getting I'm all of us I think we're
underage probably but we're in there
with fake IDs you know it's like a
teenager yeah like probably yeah we were
under 21 anyway so it could have been
caught I think it was High School
and all the like it was like the male
waiters or whatever they kept getting
people liquored up and then they would
take like this one dude Ryan I remember
they kept taking him back like into the
kitchen and I'm like damn I don't know
what's happening with Ryan bruh like
they came how long was he would they do
it like more than once oh yeah and at
first he was like I don't want to go by
the third time he's like I'll be right
back guys like you could tell they were
like kind of like picking off young
birds who were kind of Milling around
damn really you think they had any
cocaine back there or something oh God I
hope they did I wouldn't want to get
molested if I didn't have something in
me yeah no kidding I don't feel like
Anyway [__] I mean I hope not I uh I
[__] love New Orleans man yeah yeah
it's like
Key West is like my number one
favorite place to go you know visit but
New Orleans is number two I [__] love
it so much man dude Nick Swardson do you
know who that is yeah he spent almost a
million dollars during code he stayed at
a hotel in Key West he went there oh
really and I was like I'm just gonna
stay I wonder which one it was
have you ever been down there
I have been one time I don't remember it
real well man what's it like it's it's
like a hot like a beachier safer New
Orleans it's very very similar man I
went for my bachelor party it was so fun
oh my God it was so fun it's just
man I don't even know dude I that the
island time thing is such a thing down
there like nobody is worried about [__]
and like you know
it depends on what you're into but
there's like the food it's just like New
Orleans man the food there's this little
hole in the walls that are like super
authentic and like I could see that
because you're in kind of like that it's
kind of got that Caribbean Vibe huh yeah
I mean [__] you're you are 90 miles from
Cuba oh wow if they built a bridge you
could you could get there in like less
an hour and a half dang
I love it but at New Orleans man the
food
and there's something there's no other
City to me
with the culture
that New Orleans has there's it's such a
fine-tuned like distinct culture and and
like every city has this thing and like
you know the Northeast and Boston is
seafood and all that but there's just
something so [__] dope about New
Orleans yeah
yeah I guess you know I always I always
noticed that growing up I went to like
San Francisco I thought that was a
really exceptional City very unique
right yeah and um I remember thinking
Charleston was kind of cool Charleston
had a job of its own definitely it was a
kind of an Old South but still pretty
neat Chicago New York City and then I
was like New Orleans because for a while
I was like New Orleans man but then I
went around a lot of American I'm like
oh wow it's really unique because you
were kind of like kind of a cut like uh
you took it for granted in a certain way
yeah you're used to it yeah but then you
go around you're like dang bro New
Orleans is something yeah do you like
New York
I do I think there's some energy about
it I don't think I like some of the I
don't like the
like the overtly liberal [__] A lot of
it yeah you know if I'm real you know
where it's like ridiculous you know
where it's like they're uh wearing masks
to the end of time like the same kind of
stuff that happens in La yeah you know
for that either there's something about
it that's cool though right like oh yeah
there's something about it that it's the
energy that's like right no other city
has that they could build this that I
remember the first time I got out of New
York in a taxi and I was like what yeah
it looks like it's I love every time I
think I can't remember if it's JFK
LaGuardia but there's one where you can
see like a really stretched out view of
Manhattan and it's just like
so it's like breathtaking in this weird
way like there's so many [__]
buildings and [__] yeah it's crazy I
love it yeah it blew my mind man did you
guys tour uh internationally yet no
we're doing we're flying to Australia on
like March
16th Wow first time I'm so excited man
we're flying from uh uh San Francisco
too which is or San Francisco I can't
remember but uh so it's that shorter
flight it's not like I've heard there's
like a Dallas one in like a New York one
and that's like 20 hours yeah dude I'm
so stoked it's nice though dude I like
being up in the air I like if you get
yeah if you get the good if you get the
bougie like the the Pod or whatever
sometimes yeah I think I got that one
time I don't know where I was going oh
you getting that [__] you're like let's
stay up here oh yeah
you start getting angry yeah yeah the
second you get off people aren't serving
you and [__] anymore dude what's
Australia like though if you had to if
you had to compare it to anything or
describe it a lot of well they don't
have a lot of religion over there really
yeah and it's a lot of dangerous animals
dude if somebody's like hey look at this
animal yeah you know where I'm from if
somebody's like look at this animal it's
usually some type of somebody who's
trying to flash that weiner on you you
know like Sling Blade situation yeah
it's like hey you want to come see this
animal and it's just a wiener you know
with like little cat ears on or
something yeah yeah some guys like got
little in a parking lot little mouse
ears on his penis you know you're like
I'll pet it but I ain't feeding the
cheese you know what I'm saying bruh but
it's like over there it's like you know
God put nine of the most dangerous
animals ever in New York can you look it
up no in Australia I know the box
jellyfish right that's one oh they're
all bad I mean I hate to say it but it's
crazy because they put all the prisoners
in Australia and then God put all the
pretty much the most criminal animals in
Australia yeah it's kind of wild right
very wild dude yep you got box jellyfish
called the sea wasp also oh God look at
that thing so I've heard the taipan
snake it's like you you live like 15
minutes or some crazy [__] yeah
saltwater crocodile salties
that blue ringed octopus I saw a tick
tock of this kid that picked one up and
didn't know it was an octopus and then
he just like casually let it back in the
water and they were like damn if that
thing would have what does the octopus
do bite what I don't know probably just
I feel like just how does it don't
octopus have a beak or something don't
they have a little like that's a good
question can you looked at it yeah go go
to that blue octopus and let's see what
it says and can you zoom into your mind
just overall note
Dear God
they look absolutely okay they look
absolutely amazing in a fish tank but
don't touch these ball sized creatures
bite and are highly venomous this thing
is often fatal the body shuts down
becomes increasingly paralyzed and
breathing is no longer Possible Oh damn
dude there's no known that's a scariest
part no known anti-venoms so if you're
asking people for help they can be like
oh I can't help you and they mean it so
does that mean that you die if you get
bit by one oh there it is look at that
oh damn kite chitin
oh yeah okay there you go
man it kind of looks like a the math of
it looks like a vag a little bit oh yeah
definitely and that's probably what gets
you into it
some perv over there by the beach being
like hold on son I'm gonna go meet up
with this little thing you think do you
think that people in Australia you think
somebody like if they wanted to if they
wanted to like end it all would just go
find something like that like
now that is kind of nice it's almost
like God saying hey you don't need to
hang yourself or you know you don't have
to get all Brooks was crazy you know
yeah you can go the way you know the
natural way I've always said I wanted to
if I if I was gonna die I like an ant
like an animal killing me it would be
kind of kind of honorable I think
yeah you feel like it's almost like
turnabout is you know it's like it's
their turn to get one yeah yeah exactly
I don't know I've always thought that
that they were here first kind of thing
and and uh I don't know I just think
it'd be it'd be terrifying but like bit
by a rattlesnake or like
even a mountain lion or something it
would be terrifying but for yeah or just
nature dude like letting nature get you
yeah like some naked and afraid [__]
dude yeah yeah back in the day like you
could you know how Jack Daniel died the
whiskey guy he [__] got mad because
he couldn't open a safe or something and
he kicked it and his toe got infected
and it went up through his body and they
chopped his leg off and it kept going
and he died because he kicked a safe or
a heater or something but like back in
the day man like if you if you fail and
like cut yourself like you could that
was you could you could die yeah like
instantly oh dude imagine how like
that's what kind of it's like we're just
living these long like crazy we don't
even yeah that's why I think it's one of
the reasons why we have so much mental
health because we don't have it at a
certain point you don't have anything
else to do but have problems you know
it's like we've just because nature is
you're not yeah the same things aren't
happening people now they even have like
um you should be stung by a bee yeah you
were dying you know you fell off a light
you fell off like a third step three or
four yeah died yeah because you couldn't
and also
like tuberculosis
what happened to that what is it
everybody everybody died from
tuberculosis back then God it's
heartbreaking do you think that like
I wonder if like tuberculosis was just
like cancer before they knew it was
cancer uh there you go probably
are the people like is there a VA is
there a vaccine for it tuberculosis is a
disease caused by germ germs sorry that
are spread from person to person through
the air oh dude this was yeah
can people still get it though or is it
affects the lungs it also affect other
parts of the body such as the brain oh
God
kidneys are the spine imagine that it
literally sounds like covet dude yeah it
sounds definitely has very early coveted
Vibes but do you think uh
over to me and people get infected with
tuberculosis every year was there excuse
me in India or something dude yeah I
can't imagine I never met anybody with
it have you no I thought I mean no
absolutely but dude when I was growing
up people would have like you'd have a
dude who like if he got hit by something
that's just how he was I like polio or
something oh yeah you got a dude got hit
right like a baseball bat in the side
real hard and he was just like that from
now on dude you had a dude if somebody
broke their collarbone they're just
their shirt never fit right you know
just that's who they were like everybody
has spaced out teeth had a bad eye you'd
always see him at church and you finally
asked like your parents and they'd be
like well when he was a kid yeah and
then like yeah and the truth would come
out yeah but now everybody's all patched
up oh yeah for sure it's different my
scoliosis like people that was that's
such a common thing back in the day
people were just they checked at school
yeah
yeah did they do checks at your school
they would call and you'd have to bend
over and that lady would do both of them
yeah I do remember that on your back
that's right damn dude I'd forgot all
about that
they would check that damn spine boy
check that Railroad on you
school nurse dude god dude oh I we had
for one for a while we had a hot one
then we had a man dude man nurse I used
to know God
nobody got sick for like two years dude
all the guy like just scared to death
dudes were like dude I don't want to get
sick I think they were just scared of
you know just you know it just wasn't
they didn't know what a lot of people
had never seen a man nurse yeah I didn't
think I didn't think it was allowed I
thought it was like illegal or they I
honestly I truly I thought it was like
you were gay yeah like actually gay if
you were a man right it was just part of
the practice and I think early on it
probably was you know I think now it's a
little bit more Universal yeah because
you see a lot of Latino male nurses that
have like families and stuff but I think
in the beginning yeah it was like
it was like I think a lot of men used to
want to have kind of women jobs kind of
you know I think if they were I think a
lot of gay men because I think here's
probably why because they probably
weren't accepted in a lot of mail jobs
yeah I'm sure you know people made them
feel like they weren't capable like a
maid a mate like a man-made oh man-made
damn or a train conductor there's no way
if some guy was like yeah they're gonna
let him run the tray even though he
would have loved it dude yeah oh bro All
Aboard bro bro I think they should only
have gay male train conductors I feel
like could you imagine dude why would
they have anybody who wants a like a
some straight dude being like bro you
want that [__] party boy up 100 you
know how it's got like the little rail
that you know and they just do a little
grind on it and they pop up in there and
[__] go to town dude that's what I
want man damn
um does it feel weird to consider that
you've made you know this term that
you've made it it's a weird feeling
isn't it yeah I think so
man I don't know I don't I've never
I don't I don't see maybe there will
come a time but like I I always feel
like
there's a Next Step a Next Level you
know what I mean yeah I don't know
you're in the midst of something yeah
right like something is next always like
I'm still doing it yeah maybe I haven't
written my best song yet or yeah no I do
100 believe that wow I always feel like
that for sure yeah
because I don't know I think can content
can can kill somebody's career I've seen
it happen to friends and stuff you know
like
that that's definitely a thing but also
you know want to learn how to
slow down or like
I don't know feel like that you know I
appreciate moments but like really try
to take time to be like man I have done
really well and like technically have
made it you know to a lot of people and
because there are times where I'm I'm
constantly worried about the next year
and man we're gonna be in arenas next
year and the year after that we're gonna
do this and that and you know and kind
of constantly worrying about that but
it's good to check yourself for sure
what um you started a family yeah you
know that's one thing I think that kind
of starts to put down something that's
real to you yeah and you seem to really
love your wife you know I do man you
seem to really love being around her you
know I notice that when I'm around you
you guys have such a nice connection
it's admirable thank you man
um how did that kind of come to play man
did you know she was the there was no
doubt when you matter how did it go down
first night I met her man dang it was us
boy it dude I I'm again my buddy Hunter
Phelps this is so cheesy but we I we
hung out I met her at uh I was playing
drums for Hunter opening for a guy named
Jamison Rogers at Ole Miss and uh I met
her there she went to Ole Miss she did
oh damn this girl she's from San Diego
but went on this oh okay okay Best of
Both Worlds yeah it's interesting and we
met and then like she took us like went
to her apartment hung out with her
friends and then she took us
I always remember she drove us barefoot
to Huddle House oh God we ate huddle
houses she went she went to Huddle House
Barefoot oh which is big on its own oh
that's tuberculosis yeah exactly that's
ringworm [__] [__] and uh and then
like yeah if you like it put a ringworm
on
it dude exactly I'm gonna put that in a
country song I'll give you a credit dude
it won't be a good song
um but anyway and I knew that after that
night man I was like I gotta keep in
touch with this girl because ah so that
was out to keep in touch with her
there's something about her yep and I
never really I never had that with
anybody and then we went she and I we
dated we'd been dating for
like uh three or four months not long
and then when she got out of college I
she and I took a road trip from here to
San Diego to meet her parents already I
mean we just it was a one it just was we
just knew and so we drove all the way
across the country it's my favorite
memory I've ever had and so it's hers
too it was just everything like we were
like newly like in love and [__] and but
also seeing the you know the driving
across the whole country together and
like just that whole experience but we
would hit like a middle of nowhere spot
but then go to Vegas the next night it
was unbelievable and uh but anyway uh
there was never never a doubt dude it
was awesome damn yeah and did you
where'd you propose at did you do
something I did at the venue I met her
at a specific spot in this venue called
the lyric in Oxford okay I proposed I
faked a uh she she knew she she tells me
she don't she [__] knew but I faked
that I had a private show at this venue
uh on a Sunday after our Atlanta show on
Saturday and so she rode with me to the
private show and uh we go in the venue
and then like it had been like laid out
with flowers and so I did it like at the
exact spot that we we met it's pretty
cool man that's romantic yeah dude does
it feel hard to keep up with that amount
of romance because some dudes are like
oh dude I'm starting with low level
romance dude so you always have
something to work up to yeah yeah
there's there's no we're moving up you
know man I try dude yeah I
I don't know if I don't know if I would
consider myself romantic but uh I try
and it's tough man I think in any
relationship but it's just always some
so much [__] going on and like just try
to take a second every couple weeks and
like think of something you know to do
like out of the ordinary just and I
could be anything it could be like a
[__] Chick-fil-A gift card to leave
you know and be like go get some lunch
it could be anything but I just try to
do something just to keep it to keep it
you know keep it interesting or whatever
you had to be thinking of somebody else
you know yeah because that's the thing I
think in the end we want to be thought
of you know people want to be damn
thought yeah you know yep and that's you
know like the Love Languages thing you
ever heard of that oh yeah yeah hers is
like definitely
um
like uh acts of service and like quality
time and stuff like that you know what I
mean and I've learned that you know
throughout us dating and being married
but I always just try to think of that
like even if it's just like one little
thing or whatever you know yeah it's
hard though man like
this life you know it's just busy busy
busy and I come home and I'm tired and
stuff but I'm she's she deserves it so
like I really try to do as much as I can
to you know out of the ordinary for
yeah I just notice that when I'm running
it's like you really put her on a you
know you you there's no doubt that you
I feel like when I'm around you and
she's around that you
present her proudly yes I do and there's
something about that that is uh
it's like oh I I would like to be like
that yeah sure man um you know in love
with with a lady so it's easy to do when
you find the one that that you want to
do it with though like I'm never I'd
never be ashamed of was there a close
call before that was there any
we went through a little a little where
you got married though where you almost
got married before
with me and another another no that was
it nah I had like one other maybe maybe
two in the past like serious girlfriends
like I would say
like I wouldn't count as serious
girlfriend until after you're like 18
you know what I mean so I had like maybe
two over the course of
eight years before I met her but nah not
like never really considered like going
and buying a ring or anything like that
yeah just it was just like a year your
relationship or something like that
she was the only one for sure that's
cool man yeah damn she went to Ole Miss
she did she's from San Diego her dad
that California to Ole Miss no
she only knew she knew like one other
girl I think from San Diego but um she
wanted dude she's she wanted to
an experience outside of what she was
raised in and so she went and toured she
said she went and saw like Texas
uh LSU maybe Alabama and then she went
to Ole Miss and she just was like this
is where I want to go she did say that
when she went she was she thought like
you know there's a lot of people I think
she was like this is South so
everybody's gonna have like cowboy hats
and [__] and she shows up and it's just
a bunch of [__] fat frat dudes like
you know what I mean like completely
different you know than what she thought
but well especially at Ole Miss I don't
think you get the cowboy hat at it Ole
Miss no no that's a Mississippi State
though yeah yeah the Ole Miss is all the
kids from Memphis and Jackson dude yeah
definitely city city kids
City Country kids if that makes sense
yeah I think it does man that's
interesting
um Ben was there anything else in the
news that we wanted to look at I'm
trying to think of anything else that
was cool
oh dude what let me see people
yeah it says the average penis length is
growing according to a new study
the study was led by Michael Eisenberg a
Urology professor at Stanford medicine
and sexual function Specialists the
compiled data from over 75 studies done
between 1942 and 2021 damn he's been
just looking at a lot of Wayne huh
uh gathered measurements of the erect
penises of over 55 000 men God this
dude's probably in the damn closet if
he's got a wife she needs a damn knock
on the door sometimes and see what's
going on in there 55 000 men and erect
dude yeah there's no way you could look
at this many I don't want to bring up a
picture of the guy but damn dude are we
sure he's not just the findings were
astounding that's what he says dude uh
let me see zoom in on bro there's no way
that that guy wasn't born in
oh no he just looks like a dude
1942 though
oh that's when the star that's when he's
been looking at him from then oh oh okay
so he's just been looking at pictures
from then yeah or drawing how do you
even find a picture of an erect penis
from 1942. oh you I think you can get
that pretty easily I think it's some of
the rest of the it's like just putting
them all in a stack or whatever how many
is there go back to the information
please brother
let me see the finals penis length also
showed variation about go down
um let's get into some information
oh it locked up great
you know what's becoming interesting you
have to pay for news now do you notice
that yeah
so then if over time
whatever information is going to be only
available to people with money um
damn that's wild it's gonna get weird
yeah you get you read I've noticed that
like I'll see a clickback thing and
you'll read like The
though just enough and then it's like
for the rest like subscribe to
Huffington Post or whatever it is
oh there you go can we get any more
Eisenberg told Stanford showed variation
back we we all knew that already by
geographic region yeah that's that's a
given right I think so
in the article Eisenberg said chemical
exposure could be interacting with our
hormone makeup which could be one of the
many reasons that biological changes
occurring oh maybe people are living in
a place where there's more Plastics in
the water
or or could it be like uh I've heard
like kids like a 13 year old boy or girl
today looks like a like a grown-up like
has the is built like a grown-up uh
compared to like in the
30s 40s 50s or whatever because of like
hormones in the food or something like
that that's crazy dude it's weird what
we're gonna end up as we're gonna end up
like chickens in your dad's thing yeah
we probably kind of already are you know
it feels like it doesn't it sometimes
yeah
you know it feels like we all know the
same information and are kind of like
watching this you know it's like we all
get the same six news stories every day
yeah we're all kind of like stuck in the
same thing what about that train thing
are you keeping up with that that Ohio
derailment yeah it's supposed to make it
here but I don't oh that cloud is coming
here or something yes I am well I'm
gonna get a hot air balloon and go up
and get a hit cause if that [__] comes
over here you might grow a [__] tail
or something to do that dude
third arm or something dude I'll take it
bro if I had three arms dog oh what
would I do what would you do with three
arms would you go would you fight people
oh yeah I would grapple you'd make a
hell of a prostitute I think too oh yeah
dude you'd be you could juggle oh but
you'd have to juggle like five things
right yeah that's true huh you have to
really up the Annie what would you do if
I had three arms oh you could be a
really good like blackjack dealer oh
yeah car dealer
I got a hand job from this gal at Dell
Blackjack one time and I remember at the
end she went like that she went like
this she it was like
at the end dude like that yeah it was
awesome dude pretty cool and that was
over by uh I think by the win
is that in Louisiana y'all got Casino I
was in Las Vegas oh Vegas no we don't we
have two you guys have Tupelo right uh
Tunica Tunica but that's another thing
about my hometown we got two big uh
Choctaw casinos oh really out in the
country like you you top over this hill
dude and it's these two like
they're like what the size of like
Tunica or somewhere like uh like
Vicksburg like they're but there's one
that's crazy it's called the Golden Moon
and it's this like Stairway to Heaven
looking [__] with a with a big old moon
at the top corner of it it's pretty wild
it's in Philadelphia oh wow but I moved
here when I was 20 and when I was 19 so
I never
got to go and do it yeah and I was
afraid of getting out there like
sneaking out there and trying to sneak
on the floor and like getting arrested
or going to like Choctaw jail or
something you know oh yeah what did we
have
do you have one in Covington or close
no what did we have we had we had like a
daiquiri place people would go drink it
that was big in Louisiana get you a dash
oh I've heard all and they put the
little straw the thing on the end yeah
if they don't take like the thing if
they don't take the paper off the straw
clothes container right so they'll give
you that thing with that little hat on
it yeah you know dude uh it's crawfish
season oh yeah it's good I haven't I
haven't had any yet this year yeah
they're good man did you guys ever have
them up Mississippi did they get up yeah
yeah oh yeah yeah we actually just
recently in the past 10 years there's a
place in Philadelphia called Blake's
seafood and they do it there then you
can go get like a
they go you know I'm actually going to
Philadelphia tomorrow I'm playing a
little acoustic Hometown show and I'm
gonna go get some crawfish that sounds
pretty good that does sound good
do we used to go because I used to work
on a farm in Mississippi in the Summers
so I've heard you say that I go up to
Natchez right yeah and the Farms I mean
the lane was actually right over the
Levee in uh Louisiana oh really because
Natchez is on the border right yeah so
we go by like Deer Park we'd be like in
Faraday and Vidalia like right there
um and we go across and
and we'd be in uh
in Mississippi
and yeah it was nice man what kind of
farm was it it was soybean corn okay
cotton did you ever find arrowheads out
there Milo uh no but they had land
around where we go look for them
sometimes on the weekends I found them I
look for him out here go look for civil
war [__] yeah yeah yeah well Natchez
that's right yeah apparently Natchez uh
was like
that the the union came up the river and
they fired a bunch of cannons off and
that the whole city came out and was
just like surrendered or whatever
because it gave up yeah and it kind of
opened up the gate
oh Dave Natchez gave up Natchez to the
union go look it up Natchez surrender in
a civil war and they and I am they I
think they kind of opened up the gate to
because there's a lot of the battles I
don't know what they were doing then
but I could see everybody being on
something and just dude this is right
here is Big Civil War [__] really yeah
big time there's a hill right over here
called shies Hill and there's a memorial
at the top it was a giant battle people
people find uh still to this day find
relics and [__] in the ground metal do
you know what I mean like oh yeah all
kinds of stuff I'd get up my buddy says
he saw a ghost He Lives over here says
he saw a union I mean dude and this dude
is he from Mississippi no he's from uh
he's from Minnesota oh damn I don't know
if they usually like ghosts as much dude
he was laying his hammock said he saw a
dude walking like up the side of his
Hill in like Civil War outfit I swear to
God and he was like dude he was like I
don't believe in nothing and I saw this
and I was like I think I just saw a
ghost walking upside Hill where there
was like actual battles wow I could see
that man I could see there being so much
traffic right where a lot of deaths
happen at once yeah that a couple
Spirits get kind of logged in the eye
yeah something like that right ether
open that back up Ben please
there we go
this [__] looks damn
is this a play I know
um I'm sure that's pretty sure it was a
thing that they fired a bunch of cannons
and [__]
I got a damn AA meeting do you yeah
what time
in one minute oh [__]
it's at home all right word all right
cool
um
yeah will you be bummed if we and and
chat another time dude not at all okay
cool about two hours dude yeah we've
been sitting here for a while I
appreciate the time man yeah I would
appreciate you teach me about the
Nashoba County yeah dude you gotta go
dude I can't even believe it looks
amazing I can't believe I've never heard
of it I mean you could just walk and
dude like people are so inviting like
you can walk into any cabin and say hey
I'm not from here can you guys tell me
something to do and any cabin will be
like coming here feed you like
it's just it's the coolest thing in the
world God and it's hot as [__] which I
love dude yeah well you know what's
interesting man is I noticed like say if
like there's been times where I go and
stay in a hotel somewhere and then I'll
stay like in an off the beaten path
place that doesn't have air conditioning
and there's something about when you're
in that non-ac place you like wake up in
the middle of the night you're sweating
and shit's weird and it's like but it
feels like more natural yeah it's sticky
I made it nasty but it feels a lot more
nasty yeah we did that in Thailand like
we went to Thailand for a honeymoon and
like there was a couple places that were
like that and it was just like they
still have air conditioning yeah you
feel like you're just out you know
you're inside you feel like you're
outside or something
I don't know yeah yeah I think it was
just when you're more in taught in a
nature when that kind of stuff's going
on yeah you know
but yeah I could imagine that there's a
lot of places where people died at once
and then there's this bumper to bumper
traffic going to heaven or whatever I
think so and people's like I'm a mill
around yeah it's like that's like why
like uh um Mental Hospitals and like old
prisons and [__] you know where like a
lot of people died in one place they
said that's like the most haunted places
oh yeah you know what I mean I could see
it yeah
um
or at the Mockingbird and the crow
yeah congratulations man thank you very
much yeah please keep please keep
writing and making cool music man thank
you brother I love you know my sister
and I are one of my sister and I
remember was super close and we listened
to uh give uh Heaven some hell yeah yeah
yeah and do we we just Jam outside we've
never done that before that's awesome
dude so it's cool like you know we never
had that kind of even though that little
moment of fun we never had that that's
cool dude uh that's that makes my day
that's the power of music man it really
is the only language we all know how to
speak dude yeah it's pretty incredible
uh thanks for all your contributions to
it all you guys can check out Hardy uh
we'll put all his links to everything
and um and you guys can catch them on
tour on his own tour and uh with more
with Morgan and Parker and bayley learn
and earn yeah oh dude so funny I can't
wait to have earn in here yeah it's a
trip yeah he is man thank you so much I
dude this is I really appreciate it yeah
it's awesome man I'm glad we got to
spend some time yeah
[Music]
feel I'm
I'm [__] on
oh but when I reach that ground I'll
share this piece of my life
[Music]
gonna take